[Music]  the arizona cardinals have removed kyler  murray's mandatory four hours of film a  week clause from his contract why  because of the insane amount of  criticism and chatter that has been  taking over social media it did look  horrible one because it made kyler look  bad for not studying enough on his own  and two it makes the cardinals look bad  because they're giving 230.5  million dollars to a guy who they have  to apparently force to study tyler said  that it's disrespectful and it's almost  a joke the cardinals released a  statement of their own saying they are  removing the claws from kyler's contract  because of how much a distraction it has  become